hey guys and welcome to episode number
24 of my road to one bill series uh
today we're going to focus mainly on
questing in the mort area uh so items
like The Holy wrench and the salv ulet
we're going to try to get uh on top of
that uh well we just got magic level but
uh the winner of the giveaway from the
bond is going to be announced at the end
of the video so stick around that'll be
at the end and yeah let's get started
all right so we're going to buy another
4,000 astal runes uh we're going to
continue stringing the jewelry uh just
so AFK and awesome I'm really enjoying
doing it is pretty expensive uh but you
can find some pseudo Break Even points
sometimes most of the time you're losing
money but uh right now I'm not losing
too much only probably 500k an hour or
something like that there we go we're
just about to hit another magic level uh
still getting about 30k an hour doing
this which is awesome I think we're
going to cut it for now because the
prices have gone down a bit we're down
to about 2 or 300 GP loss on each amulet
which is not that great anymore uh but
still 87 per drop 130k magic experience
per hour plus uh well a little bit of
crafting is always nice only probably
10K crafting experience an hour so not
that great but um we should be hitting
did we get the perfect amount of
amulets I think we yeah we did crazy oh
hope so okay cool 82 magic that is now
going to let us use magic and bu which
is actually a pretty useful spell all
right so we've been 59 agility for quite
a while and I thought well we might as
well get 60 so we can go do the Sears
course later on uh actually kind of like
the Wilderness course to be honest uh no
problem with that exper rates are so
much better than that stupid canifis
course but anyway we're going to hit 60
agility and then we can do the seies
course when we kind of when we want all
right this should be the last lap and
that'll be uh 60 agility our end goal is
going to be 70 or 71 cuz that does
unlock quite a few of the shortcuts we
want uh mainly the Zoro shortcut and uh
the barrows uh Diaries also have a 70
requirement so it looks like my bank
Valley is 48 mil right now uh I may have
mentioned that OS buddy uh his features
are free this weekend uh so 40 50 mil in
total about 28 mil in equipment and uh
well well 3.1 in Bibles essentially a
bunch of other randoms 165k Quest items
that's interesting and two mil there and
what is war two mil here I go with a I
have two cannons okay that's weird
anyway I thought I would go ahead and
look at my entire Bank looks like about
50 mil right now okay I'm not sure if
it's just me but I really do not like
the seies course not sure what it is
about it but I feel like you fall a lot
I feel like it takes a while to get
around you got to do a lot of running
between the course got to change your
camera angle a lot I'm not enjoying this
too much so far but we're going to go
ahead and at least grind out at least
one agility level uh so we got 61 we're
going to come back to this of course but
man I got to do this in steps all right
so now we're going to start uh some
quests now the first one we're going to
do is Ghost a Hoy and now for one this
does have the Ecto file which is
extremely useful for teleporting to
morania but mainly we're going down the
tree of the morania quest line because
eventually we do want to get the barrows
hard Diaries done for extra runes uh
that we'll get from barrows when we do
it sorry did I say barrows hard di more
Tanny hard diary uh so we can get the
legs three and this is kind of just one
Quest I need to get out of the way uh so
we can do rum deal and do all the rest
all right we were fighting a giant
Lobster with a stick uh but I guess
we'll H use a uh regular sword on it h
but I don't think you ever see a lobster
ever again in the game so I thought it
was worth noting even though I'm about
to kind of roast it hey there's a guy
called Robin in the game and he's a kind
of gambling addict that kind of [__]
out his name signatures apparently if he
loses but you know whatever at least I'm
a character in the game I made it in
somehow oh my god get back here you
can't run in these stupid ghost costumes
I'm just trying to assault people at a
walking speed so it's kind of creepy to
be fair but also really annoying okay I
got all the signatures I've finally uh
convinced the town uh of something I
don't know I was skipping the quest
anyway we got it done 2400 prayer
experience mainly the ACO file and a
prerequisite for another Quest so that's
kind of nice to get that done uh the
teleport is actually really useful and
even refills it for you nice okay that
is my best Sol time so far so new
personal best is 2 minutes and 17
seconds uh didn't do anything in special
I don't believe except I am now praying
uh Eagle ey trying to get that switch
into and also a 200k drop so that's kind
of nice too okay so I believe for the
rum deal Quest I actually need to have
50 fishing uh so I got mine to 40 uh
we're just doing the trout fishing of
course uh best easy experience in the
game uh so we're going to go to 45 and
then we can eat an admiral pie which
gives you plus five boost which is good
because I really don't want to get 50
fishing all right there we go 45 fishing
only took about an hour uh still Bor is
[__] though so yeah now we can boost uh
plus five boost will get us to 50 which
is what we need for the quest Quest okay
so we're just about to start rum deal uh
now again this is a prerequisite quest
uh but the main reason we're doing this
is for uh The Holy wrench is actual rear
to get which is kind of good uh whenever
you drink a prayer potion dose uh it
restores more than a regular wood uh if
you had The Holy wrench in inventory now
I'm not sure exactly where it's going to
come in handy uh but we'll do a little
research after we get it and see if it's
going to be useful anywhere also we got
this uh uh great cut scene going on with
some zombies are looking for some rum
and uh we're going to give it to them
all right we got our distiller Tweaky
now I'm not sure what I did uh not sure
if that is intended or not but I guess
we'll go and see if we can fix it
groovy who says groovy anymore but uh
anyway we got The Holy wrench I got a
regular wrench Blast Of course uh so
yeah we'll go and complete the quest all
right that should be the quest done uh
so on top of getting the Holy wrench
like I was talking about earlier we get
to keep it uh we're going to get uh I
think we get 7,000 prayer experience
7,000 fishing experience and 7,000
farming uh two Quest points as well we
are always in it for the quest points
cuz we do want to get the barrels glove
eventually and we got both a prayer
level and a fishing level that's not bad
uh so one of the prerequisites for Cabin
Fever the next Quest I want to get out
of the way is 50 smithing and while I
could boost it uh with a spicy stew I
also have not unlocked a spicy stew yet
so I'd have to do uh some more quests
and that's thought I might as well just
get 50 smithing uh more total level
going to come in handy later so we're
just going to do it all right there's 33
smithing uh we're just making some uh
iron two-handers but mainly we're going
to do iron plates until 50 uh after this
we could do mother load mine at about I
guess 40 uh but again another Quest I
got to do so I will do that later but
for now we're just going to make iron
plate bodies all right we just hit 40
smithing uh we have another 548 iron
bars but we are definitely going to run
out so we'll definitely need to buy more
before we get 50 okay so we're just
about to hit 45 smithing I did think
about switching to like steel bars at
some point but I don't think there's any
case where I'd be losing less money it'
just be costing more and I would get
better experience but I don't know if
it's worth it anyway there's 45 smithing
all right we're just about to finish up
all the bars and finally will be 50
smithing kind of done with this it's
really expensive uh for what it is you
wouldn't think you'd lose much on iron
bars but you kind of do anyway there's
50 smithing we can now start the cabin
fever Quest okay so we're just about to
start uh The Cabin Fever quest uh now
this is mainly for experience Quest
points and of course it is a
prerequisite for some other quests but
uh it does also unlock one thing that
might be useful not sure what this yet I
want to do a little testing before I go
in depth about it but uh yeah anyway
let's get the quest started I was a
little bit
rude just Cann into a hole in our ship
oh man can't get this stupid fuse to
like this is the most awkward thing ever
I'm just literally fighting off three
people
just okay guys can you help me light the
fuse I'm just trying to blow up your
ship any second now and okay we we got
to do the end of it I guess is that
good no did we light it we failed oh
this is really awkward I just didn't
even light it correctly come on it's a
pirate attack of me for God's sake fuse
refuses the light you light the fuse
there we go all right there we go we
blew up the ship amongst like 10 people
okay there we go the quest is completed
uh like I said 7K smithing crafting and
Agility experience that is good
experience to have that being said I did
not get a level unfortunately we did
also unlock uh most harmless or whatever
you want to call it uh which may come in
handy later mainly experiencing Quest
points and it was a sick quest to do
okay and last up for the day I believe
we're going to do uh the haunted Mind
Quest uh which doesn't look like it'll
take that long but I've heard is really
annoying uh but having the Sal of
amulets will come in handy for later
although I was going to use them for
Barrows but I'm usually maging now but
uh yeah I guess we'll well I mean we'll
find a use for it later all right so
this is a really annoying part of the
quest uh you have to make sure all the
mine tracks are facing the correct
direction uh luckily there is an answer
key here but still I have to run back
and forth fix them all up uh which is
going to take a little while okay I
think I got them right and we'll see if
my mine cart actually makes it and it
looks like we're good
oh I'm glad all right so we're just on
to the
bo uh we're just on to the boss fight W
that that was actually pretty funny key
just kind of nudged away uh apparently
it's really annoying you got like this
claw attacking you and we got full Mage
gear so I think we should be fine but
this person just disappears and pops
backck up for just a second uh we got
two hits on there uh only has 100 HP so
I don't think it's going to be a huge
issue I could see if you were a lower
level this could be extremely annoying
because there's random stuff damaging
you the mine carts can do damage to you
the stupid claw machine is trying to
pick me up and uh the the [__] just
keeps moving around and you only get to
attack her once if you're using melee I
would oh God this be awful and they
actually do pretty consistent damage but
I think we'll be fine all right there we
go the quest is complete actually 22,000
strength experience is actually really
good did not even realize that going
into this uh we're also going to grab a
bunch of crystals uh so we can make a
bunch of Sal amulets and uh yeah glad to
get that out of the way and extra couple
Quest points as well all right so now
we're just adding the balls of wool to
the salv amulet looks good and uh should
be enough for a long time again you guys
have any ideas what these would be
useful for I thought barrows but I am
maging uh please if you leave a comment
below of anything that might be useful
to use a Sav amulet on um can't think
anything off the top of my head but I'm
sure it's useful all right guys so we're
going to do the giveway for the last
episode and I really appreciate everyone
who left a comment on the last video
like let's see how many load oh yeah
tons is that really satisfying watching
them all load up like this anyway
appreciate it a lot guys so we're going
to pick a winner for the bond I giveaway
from the last episode the winner is
going to
be Dean my all brown bond is good bond
is life I need a bond yes Bond I do
anyway man congratulations I'll get in
contact you uh with you through the
messenger and uh we can figure out a way
to get that Bond all right so that's
going to be it for today uh we'll have a
quick look at my count here uh notably
we've just finished uh four quests in
the mort area uh we got two magic levels
and uh what we got we got fishing levels
we got some smithing levels we actually
got like quite a few total levels up now
um our lowest stat is uh well actually
construction but just construction room
crafting and thieving are lowest
everything else is 40 or 50 all right
guys hope you enjoyed and I will see you
guys in the next
episode
n